hey guys Greg here like I said in my
trailer review for the Power Rangers I
got to bed at like 6 a.m. woke up around
4:45 p.m. I got to bed late and
overslept at the same time felt relaxed
until I woke up to see a bunch of
comments about Power Rangers and John
wig chapter 2 well everyone's psyched
about Power Rangers and I'm I was
looking forward to it John wick chapter
two was one of the highlights of the
year the first John wick came out so
this is that wait I just bought John
wick on blu-ray I wanted to watch it
again before this trailer drop is the
only time I saw was at one time in the
theaters but I got a good enough memory
of it to you know follow along with this
the man the myth the legend ice love
that classical music we've come to Rome
is this a formal event or a social
affair social how many patents solution
to and what style
can people mister wig do enjoy your
party
I've got to see you again so soon
oh you have no idea what's coming
you wanna walk
[Music]
what do you want to just give me a gun
haha [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
whoever comes
I'll kill them all
the man
the myth the legend
John wick you're not very good at
retiring I'm working on
[Music]
have eyes like this some article or
something I had no idea Laurence
Fishburne was gonna be in this that
makes this so much cooler
holy crit because like after the Matrix
Revolutions Keanu Reeves movies were
like yeah and then he had John wick come
out it's like he's back and he's in
action forum Connor Reeves is kicking
ass again and they have Laurence
Fishburne via part of John oh whoa
Morpheus now of course this is a sequel
so they're gonna amp up the action
they're gonna amp up the fun they're
gonna amp up a lot of the things that we
like gabelus what we love and more now
make it bigger and crazier which I'm all
for but what are the cool things about
the first John wick that I remembered
loving from the one time I saw it in
theaters that they had a real world
established it was more than just badass
[ __ ] man with a you know badass pass and
everything they had a world they had
that hotel I think it was the
Continental but they really showed that
there's this entire secret organization
of hitmen there's this world of hitmen
and there's something much bigger going
on and I love that aspect to it it
wasn't because this is more than just
like you know I don't know it to compare
to like it might be a bad example but
like the transporter movies all you
really get are just Jason Statham
transporter as long as he's kicking ass
and [ __ ] then that's all we need for me
I'd like I want to see more of that cool
world that they were exploring I know we
got ian mcshane coming back Laurence
Fishburne looks like he was a part of
that world too because he got this like
world of like other hitmen that you know
he's crossed paths with her had to go
into rivalry with or had to work
together with and I love those like
links to his past of him constant of him
like reentering and everyone being like
you're back John way there was a real
emotional pull towards John wick as well
as we saw in the first one that he lost
his wife his dog gets killed so you
really sympathize for this guy before he
even learned that he's a killer so while
I do want them to add everything at this
trailer showing us you know the amp
abyss of the car action sequences the
gun action sequences all that fun stuff
I still want them to continue with a
good emotional pull towards John wick
with it with something somehow expanding
it
more than just he falls in love with
someone or whatever I doesn't look like
they're gonna do that but I still want
them to figure out some way where we do
get to get more of the emotional
underlying of John wick I mean we didn't
have that moment in the shredder where
he's losing his [ __ ] and there seems to
be a strong rivalry going on or forming
with him in common which I'm glad
because common was promoted in Suicide
Squad he's barely in the [ __ ] film I
mean that same thing Apple with him in
Terminator Salvation it looks like he's
actually gonna have you know a good
amount of screen time in John wick
chapter two and of course the cool line
in the trailer do you want the war or do
you want to give me a gun and my worst
Keanu Reeves ever done anyway I mean
it's the same rider same director same
star and you got Laurence Fishburne in
there now there's how can you say no to
this movie especially if you like the
first one yes there's some tone from the
first one that's missing in the first
one a unique tone a unique style and
it's not so present in this teaser
trailer but this is just a teaser
trailer I have a lot of faith that with
the same rider same director that it's
going to still provide that same type of
tone or at least give us a tone like it
but taking in another direction you know
taking our hit Manta to Europe is always
a cool thing to do right anyway guys
thanks for tuning in you're new to the
channel subscribe today become a reject
follow me on social media yada yada yada
and shout out to carrie anne moss when
we can eat go fine lesbian ass in this
film